I created the mentality in my head of
taking no as no not right now not no
this isn't for you so no didn't have a
period it had a dot dot dot but then
there came a point when I believe had to
say like I love you thank you so much
for all your opinions but I need to now
kind of do some of this on my own
are you ambitious I mean do you have a
girl oh my god
what's up believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe in your potential and I want to
see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from actress
model and writer Lily Collins and my
take on her top ten rules of success
rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well enjoy
if I could count the amount of times I
was told no it would amount to I mean
just it was way too many times
and it made being told yes that much
better and so I created the mentality in
my head of taking no as no not right now
not no this isn't for you so no didn't
have a period it had a dot dot dot and
so if I had given up after the first
time I had said no I wouldn't be here
and so it just you know not letting
someone dictate your future if you
believe in something so strongly and you
want to do something so strongly who's
gonna tell you to not do it
so that was adapting that kind of
allowed me to take a lot of pressure off
- I like storytelling but I really like
being able to play with different parts
of myself in different characters and
you know switching it up and keeping
people on their toes as to what they
expect of me and also wait what do I
expect of myself can I go beyond what I
think I'm capable of let me try this
character and see if there's more than
to me than meets the eye and can really
relate to her and you know going from
this movie I mean it was so interesting
because I I shot the pilot for a series
that I did the Last Tycoon which is
ultra glamorous nineteen thirties
Hollywood two weeks later shooting this
then like two weeks later going off to
Korea and shooting
okhta and it was like these three
different people and I don't know I
would never have thought in my life you
know oh I'm gonna play this person this
person this person but all of them are
me they're different aspects of me and I
get to learn about myself along the way
and I get to learn from people like
Marty and amazing other actors and you
just get to you get to play and be
different versions of yourself and I
think I better understand myself through
the characters I play sometimes I think
it's probably more of a self-imposed
rule that growing up I always felt that
I almost had to keep it together all the
time to keep a composure all the time to
have all my ducks in a line all the time
and as an actor again like with the note
that Warren had given me about letting
go you just sometimes are naturally not
gonna be in control all the time and I
think once I realized that that was a
rule that I was putting on myself and
that I could just discard the world like
opens up all of a sudden these more
sponge
Haney's magical moments can happen
whether that's in your daily life
whether that's at your job I mean even
if when in your relationship with
yourself it's something so important to
know that it's okay not to have to be
perfect all the time
are you ambitious I mean you have a girl
oh my god yeah well I mean but in an
incredibly positive way look at you you
want to do all kinds of different things
I mean I feel like your ambition is more
toward experience yeah but it's very
focused they're awesome I'm very focused
but I've been very focused since I was
younger and definitely driven past what
I think people would expect of me even
though I think I'm capable of or whatnot
and sometimes I have to just take a
chill to chill pal say no to some things
but I I just I'm a believer in like
keeping lots of doors open and I really
I'm passionate about what I'm passionate
about and I think that everything can
help with everything else the writing
kind of with the acting with you know
just there's so many different things
that I like to do and I don't know why
why not you know I had fought for this
for what like six months seven months I
really wanted it and I remember sitting
there and and my agent said to me I'm I
have good news and bad news good news is
you got writers bad news as you can't do
it then why can't I do it because it was
exactly the same time as a press tour of
mine but we did the press tour while she
did our movie so she took how many
flights in and out I took 23 flights
during this shoot during the filming of
this movie yeah always knew her lies
always on time I I when I read the
script it was the first time and since
then it's been the only time I've ever
read something that I couldn't imagine
somebody else playing and whatever it
took whether I was tired or it didn't
matter for me for this project my mom
and I are really really close so she
would drive me to auditions and read
scripts and give her opinions but then
there came a point when I verily had to
say like I love you thank you so much
for all your opinions but I need to not
kind of do some of this on my own and I
stopped reading and you know asking her
to read scripts and I just became more
independent which I think regardless of
whatever industry you're in we all go
through that male/female it's kind of
like let me do my own
thing I read this a week after I had
written a chapter in my book that came
out this year where I talked about my
experience with eating disorders so if
that wasn't a sign it wasn't something I
was meant to do I don't know what is so
I read the script I knew from reading it
that it was bound to have been written
by someone that went through it I have
just been pretty recently vocal about my
experiences with with eating disorders
and I think that that's part of my
purpose just a life mission you know and
I think that when a life mission and a
work mission can can mold together so
beautifully that's when like magic can
happen if you let it there were nerves I
mean as an actor entering into a role
anyway and as someone who is now
stepping back into the shoes that they
once wore you know in something that
wasn't a positive experience for them
yes you would would enter into it
trepidatious lee but I saw it as
something so much larger than myself you
know I saw this something greater than
my story and I I knew that I had to do
it I just got I instinctually gutturally
reacted so strongly and I trust my gut
my guts done some good things a good gut
I really hate gay slurs and I will just
never understand the use of those words
and yeah I remember specifically on
dates someone using that and as like a
joke and I was like do you realize how
uncool that is and I even shocked myself
it wasn't even a thing that I thought
should I say it just came out because of
passion and I just really was against it
I think there's something so empowering
about speaking out and also you know
sometimes they say that the moments
where you're the most nervous are scared
are the most like kind of invigorating
moments in which you grow from and the
most powerful and what you gain an hour
later looking back on then you're like
yeah I told him yeah I said something
because those are the moments that
you've obviously grown from but also you
never know that could have made such an
impact on that person because no one's
actually ever called them out
and to be the first person to call
someone out that's a really strong thing
thank Sabina for your question I'd have
to say it's fun for my mom
which is the quirky things that make you
different are what make you beautiful
because I think it's such a young age
when we're not embracing our differences
we're afraid to be different and stand
out it's really important to know that
one day those things that make you
different are the things that make
unique and unique you special different
doesn't have to be a bad thing different
is beautiful I'm as ready as I'll ever
be for the challenge a dream I will
gladly be the next member I'm telling
you even the rap part I know I'm pretty
good at accents I usually do a British
one when I'm in Starbucks or some
wherever I'm getting coffee I like to
order a mocha frappuccino with whipped
cream and extra I seem like a totally
going valley girl a mocha latte but it
has to be like 102 degrees
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because on chin asked me
to if there's something you'd like me to
cover in a future top 10 check out the
link in the description and go and cast
your vote I'd also love to know what did
you learn from this video what lesson
really hit home the hardest what are you
going to immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Rebecca
Coleman Rebecca thank you so much for
picking up the e copy of my book your
one word taking that picture posting
online
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I would constantly get the note from
Warren to let go more and it's not
something that I've never been told
before so I was very hyper aware of it
when he said it and I just didn't quite
realize how useful and almost kind of
magical things can get when you just let
go and especially when you're doing take
after take after take you start to have
to just relinquish all self control in a
way and and really stop thinking so much
about what you would plan to do even as
an actor you know I know that it's all
in those spontaneous moments but you do
kind of have a bit of a guideline of
where you're going but once you get to
that you know fifth sixth seventh take
you have to start playing around in ways
that you weren't even expecting and it's
in those moments that sometimes the most
brilliant moments that would never have
happened had it just been on take one
what would happen and so I think I'm
always gonna take that with me
both my mom and my dad always have
encouraged me to do what I'm passionate
about and as long as you're choosing the
decision because you feel it's right for
you you can't have any regrets and no
one can tell you that it's the wrong
decision for you so they always knew
that I like to play dress-up and be
creative so I think it was quite an ever
table that I'll be playing characters as
I got older if you have to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]